let's say i have two transformations i
have the transformation s
which is a function or transformation
from rn
to r
m
and i also have the transformation t
which is also a transformation from
r n
to r m
i'm going to define right now what it
means to add the two transformations so
this is a definition let me write it as
a
i'm going to define
the addition of our two transformations
if i add our two transformations the
addition of two transformations
operating on some vector x this is a
definition i'm going to say that this is
the same thing
as the first transformation operating on
the vector x plus the second
transformation operating on the vector x
and obviously this is going to end up
being a vector in rm this is going to
end up being a vector in rm so this
whole thing is going to be a vector in
rm so we still are so if we the by
definition
this
s plus t transformation
is still a transformation because it
takes an input from rn
it's still
a transformation from rn
to
r
m
now let me make another definition
let me define i'll do it in
green maybe i'll do it in purple
i'm going to define
a scalar multiple of a transformation so
i'm going to define let's say c where c
is just any real number c times
the transformation s
of
some vector x i'm going to say that this
is equal to
c times the transformation of x
this is equal to c times the
transformation of x right there and so
similarly this is also this is the
transformation of x obviously is going
to be an r m so if you multiply any
vector in r m times some scalar you're
still going to have another vector in rm
so lucky luckily for us this definition
of a scalar multiple
so if i have this new transformation
called c times s this is still a mapping
from r n
to r rm
to rm
this is still a vector in rm and this is
still a vector in rn fair enough fair
enough now let's see what happens if we
look at their corresponding matrices for
these transformations we've seen in a
previous video that any linear
transformation can be represented as a
as a matrix vector product so let's say
that s
s of a vector x is equivalent to the
matrix a
times that vector x and let's say that t
of x
is equal to
is equal to the matrix b times a vector
x and of course since both of these guys
are mapping our mappings from rn to rm
both of these matrices are going to be m
by n both of these are m
by n
matrices now let's just go back to these
definitions that i just constructed what
is s of t of x can that then be written
as so let me write it this way i'll do
it in that same color
so you have s no i was gonna do it in
red
do it in red so you have maybe i'll do
it maybe i'll do it right here
you have
s plus t
it's a capital t
s plus t
of x
i'm just rewriting this up here is equal
to
s
of x
plus t of x or the transformation t of x
which we now know is equal to these two
things so this is equal to
this is equal to
this term right there the transformation
s of x
is equal to ax
that's that one right there
and then the transformation t of x is
equal to
b
the matrix b
times x now what are these things well i
can write let me write our two matrices
in a form form that you're probably
familiar with right now let's say the
matrix a is just a bunch of column
vectors
a1
a2
all the way to a n
and similarly the matrix b is just a
bunch of column vectors
the matrix b is b1
b2
all the way to bn
right these are each column vectors with
m components one for each of the rows
and there's n of these because there are
n columns in each of these vectors so
this when you multiply this guy times
let me make it very clear if i multiply
an x the vector x is going to look like
this the vector x is going to be x1 x2
all the way down to xn
and we've shown this multiple multiple
times it's a very handy way of thinking
about matrix vector products
but we know that this product right here
can be rewritten as
each of these scalar terms in x times
the corresponding column vector in a
i've done this in this probably the
fifth video that i'm doing this so this
this can be written as
x1 x1 times a1
plus x2 times a
times
a2
all the way to xn times a n
is equal to this that's what ax can be
rewritten as as just as kind of a
weighted combination of these column
vectors where the weights are each of
the values of our vector x and i have to
add this guy to bx
so bx by the same argument so plus is
just going to be let me do it in the
blue
is going to be
x1 times b1 x1 times b1
plus x2 times b2
all the way to xn
times
x n times b n now what is this equal to
well we can we know that scalar
multiplication times vectors exhibits
the distributive property so we can just
add these two guys right here and factor
out the x1 and what do we get we get
this is equal to this whole expression
right here let me draw a line here
because i'm not saying that this matrix
is equal to that i'm saying that this is
equal to this
is equal to this term plus this term
which is equal to x1 so let me write it
is equal to x1 times
a1 plus b1 a1 plus b1
plus x2 times a2
right i'm just adding these two terms up
x2 times a2 plus b2
all the way to
plus
all the way to plus
xn
times a n
plus bn
so what is this thing equal to
well this is equal to some matrix that
we you know some new matrix and let's
define this new matrix
this is equivalent to some new matrix
i'll make it pretty big
right here
times
x
times our vector x i'll do the vector x
in green
vector x we know is x 1 x 2 all the way
down to x n
but what is the new matrix going to be
well this product is going to be each of
these scalar terms times the column
vectors of this matrix so these guys
right here
these guys right here are the columns of
my matrix this thing is equivalent to a
matrix where the first column right here
is
a1 plus b1
we're essentially adding the column
vectors of those two guys the second
column right here let me draw a little
line right there to show you that these
are different expressions the second one
would be a2
plus b2
and then we'll just have a bunch of them
and then the last one will just be a n
plus b n
so what happens is that by definition
when i added these two transformations i
just used their corresponding matrices
and i said you know what this addition
of these two transformations created a
new transformation
created a new transformation that is
essentially some matrix times my vector
and that matrix ended up being the sum
ended up being the sum of the
corresponding column vectors of our two
original transformation matrices right
this new matrix that i got just and we
didn't you know i haven't defined matrix
edition yet but we got here just by
thinking about vector addition this
matrix is constructed by adding the
corresponding vectors of the matrix
matrices a and b
now why did i go through all of this
trouble well i can make a new definition
here that will make everything fit
together well i'm going to define i'll
do it in a i'm going to define
i'm going to define this matrix right
here
as
a
plus b
so my new matrix definition if i have
two matrices that have the same
dimensions and they have to have the
same dimensions i'm defining a plus b to
be equal to
a new matrix
some new matrix where you add up their
corresponding columns so a1 plus b1
just like what i did here i don't have
to rewrite it all the way up to a n
plus b n is the last column
and you've seen this before in your
algebra 2 class but i wanted it here to
do it because this shows you the
motivation for it because now we can say
that the sum of two transformations
the sum of two transformations so s plus
t
of x which is equal to
s of x this is a vector s of x
plus t of x
which we know is equal to
which is equal to
a times x plus b times x
we can now say is equal to
because it's equal to some new matrix
which we can now call a
plus b
times x right i just showed i mean this
part is from that from the definition of
our transformations and the sum of our
transformations that i defined earlier
in this video and then we just worked
this out and kind of
expressed these products as products of
or as weighted combinations of the
column vectors of these guys we got to
this new matrix and i defined this new
matrix as a plus b
and i did that because it has this neat
property now because now the sum of two
linear transformations operating on x is
equivalent to when you think of it as a
matrix vector product as the sum of
their two matrices now let's do the same
thing with scalar multiplication
we know that
we know that
c
times
our transformation of x
by definition i'm saying is c times the
transformation of x so c times whatever
vector this is in r m
and so we know that s of x can be this
right here can be rewritten as ax so
this is c
times a times x and we know that ax can
be rewritten as this is equal to c times
the x1
times the first column vector in a so a1
plus x2 times a2
all the way to plus xn
times
a n
and what is this this is scalar multiple
this is this is just going to be we can
just distribute this c and then what do
we get
we get x and i'll just and
multiplication is associative these are
c is a scalar x one is a scalar so we
can switch them around if we want we
know that scalar multiplication is
distributive so we can write this as x
one times c a1
plus x2 times ca2
all the way to
xn times c a
n
now what is this equal to
this is equal to
some new matrix times x
this is equal to some new matrix
let me make that here
times
x1 x2 all the way to n
and what is that new matrix what are the
columns of the new matrix well the
columns are now that that all the way to
that so the columns of this new matrix
are
c
a 1
c a
all the way to c
a n
now why did i go through this exercise
well wouldn't it be nice i already said
that i multi by definition a scalar
times a transformation is equal to this
is equal or a a scalar multiple of a
transformation is equal to the scalar
times the transformation of of any
vector that you kind of input into it
and of course that is equal to
c times ax now wouldn't it be nice if i
could define this thing as some new
matrix
as some new matrix times a vector x
right because this should also be a
linear transformation
and this new matrix i'm going to define
this is a definition again
i'm going to define this new matrix
as being
c times a
so now we have this definition that c
times a if i take any scalar times any
matrix a it's just equal to
c times each of the column vectors and
we know what what happens when you take
a scalar times each of let me write this
is equal to c times a1
c times a2 i'm just rewriting what i
just wrote there all the way to c times
a n but what is this in effect we know
that when you multiply c times a vector
you multiply the scalar times each of
the vectors elements so this is the
equivalent of multiplying c times every
entry up in this up in this matrix right
here and what this video you know you're
probably saying hey sal you know i
already knew how to uh you know when
algebra 2 and 10th grade or 9th grade i
already was exposed to
multiplying a scalar times a matrix or
adding two matrices with the same
dimensions why did you go through all of
this
you know trouble of defining the sum of
transformations and the sum of matrices
and i went through the trouble because i
wanted you to kind of understand that
there's nothing
i mean it is natural but there's there's
nothing about the universe that said
matrices had to be defined this way
matrix matrix addition or matrix scalar
multiplication or the addition of two
transformations i wanted you to see
that it's all kind of
weave the mathematical world has
constructed it in this way because it
seems to have nice properties that are
useful and that's what i've done in this
video in the next video i'll do a couple
of scalar multiplications and matrix
additions just to make sure that you
you remember what you had learned in in
your in the your 9th or 10th grade
algebra class but you'll find that the
actual operations are almost trivially
simple